what up guys welcome to the just pearly
thanks youtube channel today
i am going to be reacting to
wiz khalifa freestyle hello adele before
oh gosh before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it help a girl out bye
sweatshirt help support the channel
they're only available for like three
more days so
you're gonna look super cool in a
sweatshirt and we can match so it'll be
cool okay ellie stop what do you
i literally think my dog is like
growling at her reflection
wild are you can you just write to
anything
i have to feel it you got to feel it you
got to feel it out right or something
what's that yeah well
if you're gonna ask bro if you're gonna
ask
funny you ask
hello
oh my god
of me to talk about myself
[Music]
hit this weed once don't you choke
[Music]
oh my god that was amazing
that was amazing i loved that oh my gosh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wake up to it go to sleep
[Applause]
that was so good
oh my god what are we calling it um
what's her song called hello hello hello
yeah so maybe yours is high or hella o's
wow oh it's only two minutes i was
hoping it was longer
oh my gosh that was so good that's a 5
out of 5.
that might be my favorite thing i've
reacted to i think because i love adele
and i love like
genres that mix so i love like country
wrap and like pop right like i just love
mixing genres together like i think it
is so cool and it's so cool to see like
the rapper's creativity and how they can
like
take their art and like
i don't know move it onto something else
but let me know in the comments what you
guys thought i thought that was
literally amazing my jaw dropped um
don't forget to subscribe i'll talk to
you guys next time